diabetes is a disease caused by
excessive amounts of blood glucose this
condition known as hyperglycemia is
fatal if untreated and leads to various
symptoms such as excessive urination
fatigue weight loss and blurred vision
in order to control blood glucose levels
a hormone known as insulin is made by
the pancreas to signal cells for the
uptake of blood glucose type 1 diabetes
is caused by insufficient blood insulin
and is believed to be caused by a
variety of factors such as viral
infection from the rotavirus and measles
and genetics in 1921 dr. Frederick
Banting researched a successful way to
isolate insulin from pancreatic cells in
dogs they later began mass producing
insulin for diabetic patients from pigs
saving many whoreson insolent and human
insulin only differed by one amino acid
residue at the c-terminus
in which the alanine in pig insulin is
replaced with a threonine in human
insulin because of this this meant that
pig insulin was compatible with human
insulin receptors while animal
influenced are still sometimes used
today they must be very pure as there
are impurities that have been shown to
cause allergic reactions in 1926
scientists first crystallized insulin
and then in 1955 a breakthrough by
Frederick Sanger allowed scientists to
sequence the DNA coding for insulin the
3d structure was solved by Dorothy
Hodgkin in 1969 through the use of x-ray
crystallography after Sanger's work
scientists could use this genetic code
to synthesize their own insulin
efficient mass production of insulin
began in 1978 through recombinant
bacteria in which insulin genes were
inserted for bacteria to transcribe and
translate into insulin thus the insulin
that you used is mass produced by lab
bacteria for more information on type 1
diabetes and diabetes treatment and
management please visit the protein
databank website thanks for watching